[Music]
on this Friday night unrelenting rail
blockades Canada paralyzed and demands
the Prime Minister make a move the Prime
Minister has been out of the country
on a vanity project but this has been a
really difficult week for Canadians
disturbing allegations against a
Canadian fashion mogul the accusations
Peter Nygaard preyed on teenaged girls
we've all gotten this call calling you
from Canada Revenue Agency a couple has
now been arrested in this scam and while
the calls will continue and was it
Banksy and lovely surprise the
mysterious mural capturing parts
global national with Donna freezin
Robyn Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us retailers are warning
tonight store shelves are at risk of
shortages if rail blockades drag on
across Canada CN and Via Rail have
suspended operations on large sections
of their networks passengers are
stranded and businesses have stalled a
high-level meeting took place today
between the federal government and
indigenous leaders Ottawa says it's
confident talks will help end the
standoff we believe that the approach
that we're taking at the moment which
includes the rule of law but also
discussions with First Nations is the
best approach to take
[Applause]
today in Victoria protesters took their
fight back to the legislature
surrounding government buildings they're
supporting indigenous elders opposed to
a natural gas pipeline in northern BC a
handful of protesters still won't budge
from Eastern Ontario a hub that connects
Canada's capital to two of the biggest
cities but as Abigail Beeman reports
pressure is mounting on Ottawa to take
decisive action once and for all
in Ontario here's the heart of the still
standing blockade that has led to rail
shutdowns across the country I'm down
here to support them there is an
injunction to remove the protesters but
the police haven't acted on it while
across the country in Victoria an
injunction worked this well protesters
no longer blocked the entrance to the BC
legislature but are gathering outside
several government buildings federal
conservative leader Andrew Shearer says
the RCMP should move in to remove
blockade protesters they need to check
their privilege and let people whose job
depends on the railway systems and small
business farmers do their jobs we are
not the kind of country where
politicians get to tell the police what
to do the federal government encouraged
by blockades removed in Manitoba and BC
we will ensure that everything is done
to resolve this through dial
odd and constructive outcomes but in the
meantime people are affected right
across the country
now we're gonna arrive at three I'm in
Quebec I'm not happy about it
I noticed that there's some people who
are taking advantage of others online
charging up to three four times the
regular rate disgusted by others trying
to make a buck off the shut down and
driving to Ottawa from Toronto himself
tony soleil posted this ad offering
rides for just the cost of gas it was a
hot ticket thirty-six messages while bus
companies rushed to add extra coaches
almost double the capacity on a Friday
that's the beginning of the family day
long weekend for many not to mention
Valentine's Day starting late for Logan
hunt how's the girlfriend taking it as
long as I'm getting there then and it's
fine she's kind of worried but I think
I'm gonna get there Abigail Beeman
global news Ottawa the pipeline protests
started in a small pocket of northern BC
and has blown right across Canada
paralyzing rail operations and the
economy each day it's getting worse
bringing large parts of the country to a
standstill
seeing rail Canada's largest cargo
company shut down its entire Eastern
rail network protesters blocked tracks
near Belleville for a ninth day it's a
critical corridor linking Montreal and
Ottawa with Toronto via rail transports
13,000 passengers each day and canceled
all of its services yesterday and again
today with the exception of two small
routes Teamsters Canada the union
representing rail workers says the
protests are putting up to 6000 workers
out of work the blockades are choking
propane supply to people in the
Maritimes 60% of cargo that moves
through the port of Halifax does so by
rail I'm just not happy
I think there's another way to do it in
Quebec indigenous protestors blocked the
Canadian Pacific Railway tracks
strolling EXO's candy a commuter line
for a fifth day in a row it's very
annoying to be completely honest and
pretty frustrating and in the Metro
Vancouver area we're not here to create
some kind of media spectacle we're here
to shut down Canada following the call
from went away the West Coast Express
commuter train service was cancelled for
more than 12 hours because of an
overnight blockade the only people this
protest is really hurting or the average
everyday Canadians the government's not
going to be affected by this
corporations aren't going to care that
the average public aren't able to take
their train and have to take the bus
there are growing calls tonight for
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau to return
to Canada to deal with the domestic
drama that is playing out across the
country the Conservative leader says
those pipeline protesters are holding
the economy hostage and today demanded
the Prime Minister take immediate action
to restore order
Eric Sorensen reports this may be a test
of leadership unlike anything Justin
Trudeau has faced as Prime Minister over
a single project defining issues for the
nation have converged indigenous rights
resource development climate change and
what it all means for the nation's
economy we are a country of legal
processes if only it were that simple
Trudeau recognizes that even a legal
crackdown on indigenous blockades could
shatter all his efforts at
reconciliation we are working on it with
a whole-of-government approach that is
totally focused on resolving the
situation the right way but a cautious
approach isn't getting the trains moving
this former MP suggests Trudeau take a
page from his father I remember being in
Parliament with mr. Trudeau senior and
the question he used to ask is who
speaks for Canada
that's the question here today some
think Trudeau should exhibit the
toughness the TR Trudeau sometimes
flashed the greater victory is and I'm
not interested in giving them a victory
the elder Trudeau's most iconic moment
came during a very different crisis
involving the FLQ kidnapping and murder
in Quebec how far would you go with that
how far would you extend them just watch
me but when it came to First Nations
Pierre Trudeau like most prime ministers
one few accolades his
white paper essentially proposed
assimilation to eliminate Indian status
since then First Nations have engaged in
more confrontational protests such as
oka and upper wash yet even as the
courts have recognized First Nations
rights the Prime Minister finds himself
between viewpoints that seem as far
apart as ever these activists may have
the luxury of spending days at a time at
a blockade applying a term like luxury
to the lives of First Nations shows the
gulf between those who would slam
Trudeau's in action for not ending the
blockades and those who see in action as
an end to reconciliation I think most
people are feeling now reconciliation
was a farce and if it ever existed it's
completely dead now because Prime
Minister Trudeau is nowhere around to
answer for this no government has
expressed greater commitment to
reconciliation
so Trudeau hopes dialogue can break the
impasse
we have important touchstones in terms
of reconciliation in terms of
partnership it is a precarious moment
for the Prime Minister
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
despite the turmoil at home Trudeau
continued with the final stop of his
week-long for country international tour
our chief political correspondent David
akin has been traveling with the Prime
Minister David Howard domestic politics
affecting Trudeau's foreign policy
objectives well Robin this week was
designed to put Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau and Canada into a starring role
on the international stage taking
leadership positions on everything from
climate change to pressing Iran about
flight 7-5 - but back home it's likely
to be remembered for those unprecedented
blockades and protests and an absent
Prime Minister Trudeau's day was filled
meeting foreign leaders like US Senator
Lindsey Graham partnerships and
collaborations between Canada and the
United States in those meetings and in a
speech of the prestigious Munich
Security Conference Trudeau was pitching
for Canada's place on the UN Security
Council but Trudeau also took heat for
this pick taken and distributed by the
government of Iran which shows Trudeau
warmly greeting the Iranian Foreign
Minister at a meeting about flight 752
Trudeau said it was a short encounter
with one /
I went by to impress upon the foreign
minister of Iran how important it was
that we work together we ensure that
that investigation is completed but
facing a national crisis at home the
likes of which few prime ministers have
ever faced Trudeau is now having to
justify time spent abroad casting for
foreign votes we have been fully engaged
fully seized with this as a government I
myself have been on direct phone calls
with premiers like premier Horrigan and
with my team our Deputy Prime Minister
has met and connected with all her
provincial and territorial counterparts
and Trudeau refused to say if he thinks
the coastal gas link should in fact be
built across northern BC nor would he
say specifically how he will enforce
Court rulings that allow that gas line
to be built we are a country of the rule
of law and we will ensure that
everything is done to resolve this
through dialogue and constructive
outcomes Trudeau returns this evening to
Ottawa but his schedule has him on the
road again on Monday heading to Barbados
to continue his campaign for UN Security
Council votes
I asked Trudeau if his schedule stands
and he says it does for now but after
the weekend we'll see Robin David akin
in Munich thanks David the RCMP has
arrested an Ontario couple as part of
its investigation into fake Canada
Revenue Agency calls
officers seized thousands of dollars
jewelry and a money counting machine
when they arrested ger interpret and
interpret Dulli Wall on Wednesday
they're facing several charges including
laundering the proceeds of crime police
have also issued a Canada wide arrest
warrant for Shunta gnomonic more arrests
and charges are expected investigators
say the CRA scam has been operating out
of India since 2014 resulting in
Canadian victims losing more than 17
million dollars they continually to
continue to evolve the scam you're
certainly if you've got a cell phone a
landline you're getting calls
essentially related to the service
canada scam and thus in number scam
we're doing our best to do whatever we
can to
to stop it and our efforts will continue
if someone calls you asking for personal
information you should hang up and
report it to the Canadian anti-fraud
centre if the caller is threatening you
call the police
as Cova 19 has spread so has the
misinformation coming up the rumours
hoaxes and the BC man who mistakenly
became the face of the virus there's a
new presumed case of covin 19 in Canada
today health officials in BC say woman
in her 30s has tested positive for the
virus
she returned from Shanghai last week and
had not been to Hebei province the
epicenter of the outbreak her symptoms
started we think around the time of her
arrival we were still working out those
details and looking at the flights and
whether she we need to contact people on
those flights once home she had contact
with a small number of people who are
now self isolating if this becomes a
confirmed case through national lab
testing it will bring Canada's total to
eight overseas Canadian health care
workers are now in Japan assisting 12
Canadians who have the virus they
contracted it while aboard the diamond
princess the cruise ship has been under
quarantine in a Japanese port since last
week the World Health Organization will
begin investigating the outbreak in
China this weekend the team led by
Canadian doctor will focus on how the
new corona virus is spreading and the
severity it will also gather more
details on the impact it's having on
those on the front lines more than 1700
medical workers have been infected by
Kovan 19 six of those workers have died
from the virus this outbreak has come
expanded very quickly in an unsuspecting
health system so we also need to look at
how many of those health workers were
exposed unknowingly within a clinical
environment according to Chinese media
the number of confirmed cases globally
is now at more than 66-thousand most of
them are still in China the death toll
has risen to more than 1,500 people
nearly all in China
health experts with the WH ojas
wrapped up a meeting in Silicon Valley
they met with tech giants including
Facebook and YouTube to discuss a
different kind of outbreak the spread of
false and deliberately misleading
information about the new coronavirus
Jeff sample reports BC resident Jerry go
hasn't visited China in a year and his
feeling just fine which is why he was
surprised to see this one day like well
my friend suddenly told me Oh Jerry you
are famous right now his photograph
appeared on this local news website in
an article about the new corona virus
and face masks go was dropping off his
girlfriend at Vancouver's Airport at the
time and didn't realize his photo was
being taken but before long it turned up
again and after that like a lot of
Chinese articles are using that photo
that image has since appeared in
numerous other online articles and
shared widely on social media in posts
warning about a man who arrived in
Vancouver from Shanghai infected with
Koba 19 they were using my picture as a
cover of the news and the news was not
related to to me the outbreak has
sparked a slew of misinformation false
information about the virus itself has
spread faster from the virus with
websites claiming the virus can be cured
by eating garlic or drinking carbon
dioxide the UK's top tabloids claimed
this satellite image shows the mass
burning of bodies in China from the
outbreak it's actually a NASA image
based on weather patterns another
popular conspiracy theory on Twitter
claims the virus was stolen from the
microbiology lab in Winnipeg or is a US
bio weapon medical experts believe the
virus actually originated at this
Chinese live animal market with almost
certainty that was created whose origins
were from bats so all of these other
origins stories about people concocting
these things are completely untrue the
World Health Organization met this week
with social media companies to stop what
it calls an info Demick this is the
first time we have seen
major epidemic and major social media
going on at the same time I think we'd
be better off without both of them
Facebook is now responding to those
concerns by directing its users to the
w-h-o website
health experts stressing that in an
ongoing outbreak it's best to go
straight to the official source Robin
good information
thanks very much Jeff still ahead the
Canadian fashion entrepreneur accused of
disturbing crimes
ten women have filed a class action
lawsuit against Canadian fashion mogul
Peter Nygaard the lawsuit alleges he
sexually assaulted the women at his home
in the Bahamas as globals Brittany
Greenslade reports Nygaard is denying
the allegations he's a multi-millionaire
a Canadian fashion tycoon and now Peter
Nygaard is at the center of a
class-action lawsuit
containing bombshell allegations that
complaint lays out a scheme of human
trafficking that's been happening at an
international level and during the
course of this human trafficking
endeavor that's been ongoing for over
ten years ten unnamed women alleging
they were raped by Nygaard nine of them
claiming the assaults took place at his
Island estate in the Bahamas the
class-action lawsuit claims Nygaard
recruited lured and enticed young
impressionable and often impoverished
children and women with cash payments
and false promises of lucrative modeling
opportunities to assault rape and
sodomize them this video link was part
of the lawsuit the YouTube video posted
in 2018 is called pamper party at
Nygaard Inc and shows Nygaard
interacting with young men and women it
was at these pamper parties the victims
some as young as 14 alleged the
incidents happened are complete lays out
a pattern of abuse using drugs to be
able to enable a person not to be able
to resist him because to be under the
influence
heavy intoxication brute force
intimidation and sometimes just plain
bribery scandalous allegations they're
false allegations totally false and they
will and are being vigorously denied by
by Peter Nygaard Nygard lawyer says the
allegations are a byproduct of a 10-year
feud with his bohemian neighbor and New
York billionaire Lois bacon Lewis bacon
the hedge fund billionaire is paying for
at least four women who claimed that
they were sexually assaulted the
so-called plaintiffs
our making accusations that are false
manufactured and paid for
none of the allegations have been proven
in court Nygaard lawyers say they plan
to file to have the case dismissed
Britany Greenslade global news up next
roses are red violets are blue but did
Banksy give Bristol a new piece to view
British Street artist Banksy appears to
have given his hometown a gift just in
time for Valentine's Day
the mural shows a small girl with a
slingshot and a splatter of red flowers
it's on the side of a house in Bristol
England a city about two hours west of
London as crystal commencing explains
Banksy's art often plays with elements
of darkness and joy and this piece is no
different
Marsh Lane is getting a whole lot of
love we were just working around the
corner and then someone was saying that
all covers the new banks around the
corner so yeah just immediately spoke
enough work surely lots of people left
work early to see the new Banksy and
more will be flocking to this Bristol
England neighborhood although some worry
how the piece will fare with a storm in
the forecast a lovely surprise really
nice
yay oh just driving down the road to go
and do some shopping and there it was so
I had to stop and have a look it's just
amazing amazing yes but is it about love
it did appear on Banksy's Instagram page
on the 14th Bristol is reportedly his
home but little is known about one of
the most recognizable names in street
art we do know he is a master at making
people gasp remember this
nyancy is one of a kind you know but he
is not the be-all end-all you know he's
a it's very clever artist yes for his
messages self-expression fills every
inch at Leake Streeter Banksy tunnel in
2008 the space under Waterloo station
was transformed by the mysterious
painter when he hosted the Cannes
Festival
Banksy's work can be found all over
including around the corner from the
Global News London Bureau we went to the
back to the exhibition don't waste that
when they had the dismaland and we were
just driving past the saw so everyone
here so we thought we'd stop in our book
along gaze and a few pictures maybe the
point of this Valentine's Day Banksy is
to get people to spend time together
doing something that costs nothing
Christo go Manson Global News London and
that is global national for this
Valentine's Day I'm Robin Gill tonight
your Canada is this lovely shot of two
swans near Victoria BC we would love to
see your part of the country so email
your pictures to viewers at global
national calm thank you for watching and
I'll see you back here all this weekend
have a great night
[Music]